hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to let's play don't
starve okay as you can see we jumped
forward just a little bit I was
exploring during the night and I was
following the signal of this but you
guys informed me had found pieces with a
puzzle that I need to assemble the bank
Maxwell's door because Maxwell door
doesn't exist in this world I need to
create it so what I have found here is
something strange that I have never seen
before in my life however that will not
stop me there's some weird horse
creature check it out man some strange
horse is a bunch of clockwork things in
there after me so I didn't know if they
were evil at first so I just wanted to
see this man what is going on here this
is weird
Oh what was that you gotta be joking
fish oh no oh no oh no whoa no I cannot
die no no no okay I need to stay the
hell away from there man okay so I saw
something that was necessary to make it
look like I think it might say the frame
that I needed to make the door but um
that doesn't help me really right now
damn it and I was right by my thing too
let me see if I can get by the fire down
there hmm I don't like these people
these people freak me out
I need to cook up some of these berries
so that and get some health back no
don't eat me a stupid goober put them in
the fire and cook him up you silly silly
sack of potatoes
alright we need to slab these together
because our health is not doing very
good at all yes yes divining-rod
shut up okay now eat I know it doesn't
give much health wow it doesn't give it
it like does a little blip on the health
radar but it doesn't actually do
anything so nevermind knows a fruitless
effort I don't think the green cap gives
off either I think I tested that damn it
man I am not doing well here
Oh suspicious dirt pile well dammit I
went up all this way to try to find
something new but I found something new
but how unfortunately it couldn't help
me in the way that I wanted it to do
because it said that my ax wouldn't cut
it and then I was basically screwed I
think I think it's setting not so many
words you are screwed mark claret even
said my name it knows who I am
so unfortunately I am screwed and I am
going to die my sanity is also suffering
something fierce in my stupid glowstone
did not heat up enough I think it heats
up faster if you do drop it because it's
just in my inventory doesn't seem to
heat up at all but when I take it out of
the inventory seems to hate it faster
well maybe I'm lying and you are gonna
call me out is it dirty dirty liar who
tries to tell false information to other
people who tried to play this game
however I do what I need to do to
survive
blow hotter hot glower glow hot hot hot
I like it hot hot hot yes I like it hot
hot hot all right let's go our sanity is
still not doing very good but we don't
have much of a choice here there aren't
exactly many flowers to pick during the
winter so we just got to make do with
what we have and what we have is not
very much is that a flower I'm gonna
bake it oh I feel so much better now
stupid son of a gun Oswald or whatever
your name is loose
Oswald Luis danger felt I don't know
what your name is
ooh that does not look good walrus Camp
walrus camp
hello oh no thank you
what is that you drawn a blow dart you
know no blow dart to me
I can't believe holy crap they are going
to murder my face off
what hell I was just trying to be nice
and friendly I thought they were gonna
be like the pig man but no walrus no
like pig man holy hell stay away from
walrus if you want to live my goodness
and also I'm an extreme distance away
from whatever my we still want me no no
no no no no blow dart
no blow dart no boat now you hit chesty
I need to get these no what do you're
not giving up don't eat yes sir no not
just her just aw come with hither a
chest oh they don't want to give up damn
it why don't they give up no Chester
police keep moving thank you thank you
oh I thought they were gonna hit that
bird but no they hit Chester instead
those douches and I'm about to phrase
they're not going well everybody this is
not going well this may be the end of
with a crashing exploding wait a minute
those a totally different game this
might be the end for stupid pants
McGillicutty I don't even remember what
is it I know you guys have told me what
his name is over and over again but I
keep forgetting Lewis stupid pants move
faith is dumb McDonough still our uh-oh
I think they finally gave up the chase
okay Oh what the hell stay away it's
night time go back to your home did they
actually go back to their home or they
just decide to not be a douche anymore
yeah I'm not gonna survive I've got no
health
I've got no nothing I've got no hope
I've got no items I've got no skill I am
not pro enough for this I am NOT bro
enough to survive in this desolate
environment
whoa yes actually what I'm going to do
is I'm gonna make a hello wait shut up
I'm trying to buy a vowel yeah uh never
mind forget all that no one cares no one
cares it all weighed we just got to
survive than that so Oh
okay all right welcome back everybody of
the morning of don't starve we have a
nice hot heat stone a nice hot heat
source that we can use to move forward
into the life that we don't want to live
anymore because frankly I'm surprised
this guy hasn't just given up already
because wowie wow wow wow are we ever
screwed with how little amount of health
that we have I can't believe there's a
stupid light bulb on his head thing that
was dumb adventure mode is hard I am not
good enough for this game I am not at
all I mean I thought I knew what I
needed to do but man this is something
else I know a lot of you guys are
probably like Greg come on mark you're
so pro you you're like the best gamer in
the world I mean there's no way that yes
I can be beaten by some games
I know it's rare but oh dammit
hahaha no don't kill me I'm trying to
get back don't kill me don't murder me
don't murder me
oh my God why did I walk straight
through all of the wolves why did I have
to go through this way why did I have to
go through every single wolf in
existence ever hello
yeah wait I'll get to you in a second
hold your horses ah okay alright okay
all right wolves going away okay alright
okay alright it's gonna cry just gonna
cry myself to sleep this could've caught
a whole huddle up in a little ball and
cry actually what I'm going to do is I'm
gonna take this road out to the west
over here to see if I can find somethin
else you know when I first went into
adventure mode the first time winter did
end they did like on the first day you I
had video evidence that winter ended but
now winter days forever forever in this
land
okay I think I need to take a moment to
to chop me up some wood because I am
getting low on wood and if I run out of
wood during the winter I am scared I
have plenty of food I just need wood man
this game is out to get me everything
about this game is just out to get me I
wouldn't be surprised if as I'm chopping
trees here
yeah I'm it whoo damn it fire do the
fire okay I wouldn't be surprised if as
I was chopping these woods here that
giant tree monster that I've heard so
much about just appears out of nowhere I
would not be surprised good I saw that I
was watching that whoa that's turtle me
cuz ah you guys have told me that it'll
happen randomly or if it's if it's a
specific tree that I chop down or what I
honestly have no idea what I need to do
to make that happen but hoping it
doesn't okay we seem to be good I'm not
gonna test it anymore
with any more wood I've got enough wood
nature that's enough just leave me alone
now I gotta sit here again because I
gotta wait for this stupid heat stone to
heat up because I hate my life those
give tiny tiny tiny tiny amounts of
health not even not even anything
considerable and my sanity is still not
doing well because I might as well cook
them just cuz they give like an infant s
amol amount of health yay two points two
points of health good for me good for me
markiplier you're the best ever oh
you're so great at everything you do
it's not getting late you're just made
of fire Hey look gold why is there gold
just sitting here why is it just sitting
here what's going on eh oh no it's a
grave hang on a second what hang on a
tick hang on a tick I'm gonna make some
that I should have made a little bit ago
I'm gonna make a science machine because
I had the materials for a while
what I wanna do wouldn't wanna do is
make a shovel because I've been needing
to make a shuttle for a while now
because I'm going to dig in this grave
no monsters ball in a cup
everybody loves the ball in the cup ball
and accompanies are gonna do okay
whatever stupid jokes with balls in the
cup will give you some balls in a cup
game don't test me kill the farm what
happened all that Beefalo oh yeah I died
I met the thousands of Beefalo back in
the other one where I died before and
now I've got no poop to help me out on
my journey
if the weirder sentence has ever been
said in their entire life I would like
to hear it but now I officially am all
at a poop and all out of hope oh look
more graves let's dig him up let's see
oooh lying robot my sanity really
suffers when I dig up a grave which is
probably not good but at this point I
don't really care
Hey look a blue gem that's probably good
right right right
wrong wrong just like everything else
I've done in my life I am wrong oh well
I will carry one even though I think
that I may die soon and I see visions
out of the corner of my eyes phantasms
of my past are starting to haunt me
Jesse
help my sanity get a little better
Chester Chester are you going to help me
you're not going to help me you're not
even real are you nothing is real hey
wait a minute
is there a face on my shovel is that
something that's appearing because I'm
going insane it really looks like
there's a face on my shovel I don't
think that's I don't think that's normal
I don't think so it really looks like
there's a face on my shovel I'm not sure
I might get finally pay losing it
everybody I might finally be stopping
which is totally possible it was what is
this feel gonna end that's a big tall
bird
I'm cold again okay so cool I hate my
life my life I'm gonna run out of
materials to build these you
but fires burn myself alive it's getting
out of hand we'll stand right on top of
it you're fine
just heat yourself up by this blazing
hot fire and let your heat stone go ah
whatever whatever we're just gonna zoom
forward so whoop de frickin do okay good
morning everybody I'm not doing very
well as you can plainly see I was gonna
make an advanced science machine or
whatever the next step is called I don't
remember the names of anything because
I'm a complete however I don't
have enough raw materials to do anything
even after I built it which I only need
a little bit more stone to do it but
even if I built it I wouldn't be able to
do anything about it so here I lie
wallowing in my own self-pity until I
die a natural death I even saw phantasms
of my family in those shadows of the
night however I am still screwed because
I don't have anything to raise by Oh at
least I don't think I do that green
mushroom might be able to but I'm not
exactly sure if that does and if that
does actually hurt me which it might
know like some of the mushrooms I don't
remember which mushroom does what so if
I eat it it probably gonna kill me and
then I will have to start all over again
and then I will be very pissed off I
will be very angry I'll be markiplier
angry and everyone knows that's super
angry also my sanity is dropping to ABS
abysmally low levels and I shall die
forever
hello berry bush at least just something
of comfort in this dark and dreary woods
man this place is friggin huge I can't
get away from everything it seems like
the biomes are getting even bigger than
they were before and my hope is quickly
dwindling
I'm going to die I'm going to die I'm
lost I'm lost uh where's the
blacksmith's please
ah-ha yeah all right
seriously I don't know I don't even I
don't even know where to begin to try to
get my health back up all I'm trying to
do is what I should have been doing a
while ago was with my divining rod but
there might have been an item over there
now I wouldn't know because I was being
an idiot and then Paul I'm a freaking
divining rod why I don't know I don't
know what I'm doing I don't know
and how do I even get the schematic in
order to build Maxwell's door so that I
can do anything after I get the way that
I need to go there's so many questions
all I'm gonna do is I'm gonna head back
to the pig village and talk with them
because I want them to like me
ergo it's the only thing that I've got
at the moment and I've got no hope
nothing else nothing I have nothing
absolutely nothing got done this this
episode I hope you all hate me after
this you're like ah mark why this is the
most boring thing I've ever seen in my
life yes I know
hi Brooke how are you you're much nicer
than those stupid a whole firm firm head
I'm talking about what were the walrus
stupid
walruses anyway I'm done I'm starving
I'm dying I'm gonna cook all these up
before they spoiled it wrapping back I'm
so hungry shut up I know what best I'm
cooking you up a meal sucks huh just eat
it
stuff your face with every of it I owe a
guy life
thank you all so much for watching I
will figure this out later I'm gonna
take a I'm gonna skip ahead next steps
is gonna be a bit of a time jump between
this episode in the next episode because
I'm gonna skip ahead and try to figure
out a way to get to where I need to go
I'm gonna actually go in prepared in the
next episodes there's gonna be a time
jump from there to here so thank you all
someone for watching click the
annotation for more videos it I've done
and as always I will see you in the next
video
Oh
I do not like this
hmm